catherine deneuve bonsoir alors est ce
que vous vous pensez que ce couple
finalement cette aventure de raoul ruiz
dans l'univers crous c'est une réussite
parce que d'autres réalisateurs ont
tenté l aventure
beaucoup ont échoué a été détrôné sais
pas je pense pas que beaucoup de
réalisateurs et échoué je crois que
malheureusement il ya eu beaucoup d'aidé
décès de tentatives de te de monter un
film sur proulx s'est il finalement il
n'y a eu qu'une kindia coach enders qui
a fait un film
moi je sais pas ce que je suis lié au
projet de coûts depuis très très
longtemps et on m'avait proposé le rôle
d'albert s'il ya fort longtemps quand le
film de versailles il ya une trentaine
d'années déjà et puis voilà c'est odette
avec le temps ci m'a été proposé mais
c'est très très difficile à c'était
difficile à monter c'était difficile
aussi peut-être d'avoir le à la fois
l'audace et une forme de courage aussi
de la part de raoul ruiz et de gilles
taurand qui a écrit le script des perles
au branco qui l'a produit c'est quand
même quelque chose qui tente tout le
monde et qui fait peur en même temps
vous venez de dire c'est pas le rôle
dont vous rêviez celui d'odette et
qu'effectivement vous auriez précieuse
sud albertine enfin c'est ce que vous
pensiez avec le thé tisane et avec le
sens oui d'accord je suis passé
d'albertine à odette par la force des
choses albertina 18 ans bon mais vous
vous je m'étrangle 1 me dit ah non il
n'y a pas de rôle plus ou moins vous
dans le dans le fil tous les personnages
existent et même s'il n'existe pas je
dire à l'image parce que c'est le temps
retrouvé qui a été tournée il existe
tellement dans la mémoire de dea
d'histoire et de tous les personnages
que ce sont des personnages qu'on
connaît avant même de les voir dans le
film ce sont les personnages qui ont une
légende quand même alors là vous
développez vous même une philosophie du
temps retrouvé quand vous nous parler de
cette différence de propositions entre
deux rôles celui d'odette vous plaît
quand même oui mais vous avez l'idée
c'était pas ça va si le roleplay jeudi
l'idée c'est de rentrer de dire est ce
qu'on parle dans cette aventure de de
proust et dans le si vous laissez pas
j'ai pas cherché à voir si mon rôle
était plus long que celui des non non
c'est pas ça c'était le c'était nous
étions tous embarqués sur sûr c'est
énorme énorme paquebot qui était le
projet lui même et je crois vraiment
qu'il ya une une atmosphère très
particulière entre
le metteur en scène les acteurs sur le
tournage je crois vraiment vu le nombre
d'acteurs et d'actrices qui ont
participé au film c'est très rare de
voir une telle unité parce que tout le
monde avait envie de faire le film de
bruce avant même de penser vraiment
personnage c'est une envie de participer
à cette fête choses un peu un peu
mythique vous avez tourné 85 films je
crois vous êtes la star française
catherine deneuve
vous avez entre envie d'explorer comment
je dis vous avez participé à 85 films je
crois vous êtes la star française
catherine de même est-ce que vous avez
encore et toujours envie d'explorer le
cinéma de lui de lui donner quelque
chose mais je pense pas je pense pas je
pense pas de donner quelque chose je
pense que c'est aussi très égoïste
quoique l'idée de ces l'égoïsme la
curiosité d'avoir envie de faire des
choses aventureuse avec des gens qui
m'intéresse et l'impression de de faire
des choses différentes que ma curiosité
me pousse à explorer enfin j'espère
enfin pour moi en tous les cas c'est mon
attitude
je pense que si vraiment j'avais
l'impression de faire des choses qui se
répétait je pense que j'aurais plus
tellement envie de continuer mais pour
l'instant c'est comme ça chaque séquence
est bon tant mieux
vous êtes à cannes pour deux films
politiques notamment vous en parlez
bruit - pardon je dis vous êtes
également là pour pollet x cannes ce
film dont vous parlez beaucoup moins ce
tournage on a moins marqué apparemment
mais c'est vous qui m'avez fait et rusé
surprise oui oui bien sûr la fin du
journal
absolument mais je suis pas le seul à
vous interroger sur sur les films
auxquels vous avez participé qui sont
présentés à cannes
et effectivement je vous demandais si
si pola x vous avez moins marqué que le
surcoût ce que ne sont pas jamais vitale
et non je ne compare pas du tout c'est
pas parce que les deux films sont à
cannes on peut pas se dire on peut pas
on peut pas simplifier je veux dire
comme ça la présence des films à cannes
c'est pas parce que les films sont à
cannes qu'ils peuvent être comparés à
cagnes à tous les films qui ont été
sélectionnés ce sont tous des films de
son des films de genres très différents
c'est pas parce que les deux films je
vais sont en compétition dans la
sélection française qu'ils ont il n'aura
absolument aucun point commun aucun
point commun vraiment c'est mais si vous
me posez des questions sur twilight si
jamais vous l'avez lu je vous répondrai
volontiers
et là je ne les ai pas vu hélas nous
n'avons pas le temps tous les cas à 91
merci merci d'avoir participé à ce 19e
en direct de cannes et puis bon festival
ma foi